[Music]
season finale of Dancing with the Stars
thank you the ballroom was full of
energy Tuesday night as finalist David
Ross Rashad Jennings and romani Corday
competed for the season 24 mirror ball
trophy first they performed their
favorite dance of the season
check out judges Len and Bruno in Norm
Anees number yes that's them as
construction workers
[Applause]
[Music]
then the final three were put to the
test they had 24 hours to learn a
mash-up of two styles of dance for David
and Lindsey a Foxtrot salsa
[Applause]
nor money and Val crushed their Foxtrot
tango
[Music]
ditto damn you back and Rashad and Emma
turned it all the way up with their
cha-cha tango three incredible routines
but only one Mirrorball trophy the
couple in third place is normanni and
now the crowd visibly stunned nor
Manny's fifth harmony bandmates were
even a bit emotional the winners and new
champions of Dancing with the Stars are
Rashad
[Applause]
and more good news we're shod we'll be
the celebrity guest on the Dancing with
the Stars hot summer nights tour which
kicks off June 15
[Music]
you